favor of Aldo Jones right uh yeah from
inglourious basterds and you have your
pieces
there's the weird trailer you should do
weird trailer guarding to the galaxy vol
2 [ __ ] dear where my DC shirt today oh
man you must hate [ __ ] everything
Marvel yeah [ __ ] fanboy oh my god
Marvel with dick right now I mean do you
see you know why do you hate everything
that the people love you snagged all
over that King Arthur legend the sword
trip I'm not gonna matter what I'm gonna
plug okay I'll be your wingman yeah whoa
the sort of what you think and gun for
one but I guess we both doing good now
I just dunno
[Music]
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
whoa ha ha what oh whoa
Batman whoa Wow how evoke Peter
crazily working sometimes the people
blow for my whole life
that's right there by your side all ooh
[Music]
the tank
I sent you to those planets to teach you
about justice how are you I am your
father
oh wow you know that like because it's
guardians of the galaxy's that flowed
really well yeah now I'm not going to
try to look for your items you know why
because it's the biggest pain in the ass
to find every [ __ ] video you try to
look for them and then I give up any
video that makes hefty use of a douche
spider-man is good in my book
Aldo listen you guys subscribers Aldo
guy yeah there you go yeah scribes I
don't know it kind of felt like it could
be a real thing in a weird way well cos
guardians the galaxy's of Gerrits and
there's so many different the world yeah
you can be a part of an in that like
it's such an expansive universe it looks
like a trailer for a thing we were like
oh that's a cool trailer for a movie
that might be kind of annoying this is
all the could've Yuri
you know like it's that like really zany
like right out of energy like you know
but come fury like a half hour or
something is out onto trees you know but
if you better this is a 90-minute movie
but if someone says like oh there's a
half hour movie then they show me this I
believe like oh there's a night me up
for that so she has a weird crazy moving
yeah a weird or like rejected yeah
exactly
and hey dude you throwing the cast of
friends I know all you do is yell at
each other you know my favorite show is
of all time Jon how say with me How I
Met Your Mother
how I met your friends how I friends are
in Rachel Rin Ted Rachel Barney Dharma
and Greg what was that thing with Peter
Dinklage dancing that's from innocent
help skit from the away from a missing
Game of Thrones episodes it is they just
repurposed it it got cut out so they
used it well I could see how our game
okay
so like a deleted scene that got popular
I got you yeah yeah this whole there
supposed to be like one whole episode
where Tyrion time travel yeah travel
then kind of has this weird mental break
and starts you know at know what Street
singer-songwriter career Game of Thrones
takes place in the past yeah but you
know in fantasy so you know the physics
are up for debate
and so yeah that was a big there's going
to be there fly episode like in breaking
oh yeah but yeah george RR martin just
wasn't jazzed by it it wasn't in the
books at all so they gave a test now
instead looks good i'm glad we are glad
we did this
I'm glad we did I'm glad we committed to
this nation I was really in the whole
time I know I could tell hey man that's
what happens when you get people who did
improv once together guys you know what
I'm going to leave aldo a comet dear
aldo jones comma i want you to know that
you are one of the most talented people
on youtube i think your videos make me
want to donate to charity you have
inspired me to tell people that I'm
inspiring too I love your beard and you
have a really hot wife does Elmo Jones
of hot way yes yes he does I would like
to invite you and your wife over for
dinner sometime next week at my home in
Pacific Palisades Fredersen in Pacific
Rim that's where rich people live
that's where rich me
allow me time to seduce you and your
wife into a twosome involving me and
your wonderful young good
JK I want to watch you and your wife
keep your hair down beard groomed and
socks on here's John hey Aldo John here
you may not know me you have my dukes
I'm bad at I'm confusing you may not
know me it was exactly like your I know
you we've been watching you for many
months now we've been watching for you
for many months thanks your power is
growing soon we will not be able to stop
it funny videos the hilarious games
Batman's newspaper where does the
madness end if you turn yourself in now
that'll be the end
if you don't I will find you and I will
kill you but first can you do one of
these for like a Saw movie or something
or you know just anything horror a big
horror guy anyway I'm running out of
jokes obviously we get it on here
handing it off to the G train uno mas
tiempos hashtag Spanish Greg here
I request you do a weird trailer for
Passion of the Christ I think the
controversy would be good for everyone
ever PS I found all the items the first
time I watched it watch this video
you're sucking at hiding them because I
found them right away get better at your
life I love you Greg
oh man I hope you read it how Pikachu
this is posted on this page way before
this to the hood it's okay it's all
going to come to get all the pieces it
is good no one's going to realize that
this back to the rejects has been
marketing man its marketing this is
viral marketing well you can subscribe
to Aldo Jones hey you can subscribe to
the real rejects can you can follow John
on reasons Jerry at Twitter and
Instagram and he is the social media
manager of the lung house and the real
rejects shoutout to tyrone Magnus he is
almost at 1 million subscribers
woo I don't know why he's not there yet
might have something to do with this
YouTube algorithm which I think has only
benefitted this channel have you seen
the views in the last few months they
have gone through the roof so much
higher than before the algorithm change
yeah totally it's it's really just we're
making too much money right now I love
YouTube and shrunk goodbye